dit au chefx : vous devez en
faire plus concernant les armes
à feu.
- Bonsoir.
- Est-ce que j'ai raison de dire
que c'est quand même rare que
cinq maires se mettent ensemble.
- C'est un dossier tellement
important qu'ils avaient besoin
de faire parce que c'est quand
même cinq grandes villes.
Cependant, demander au
gouvernement de s'occuper des
armes : aussi c'est la
responsabilité moi je pense
gouvernement canadien. Les armes
circulent partout. Ça réglera
pas le problème convie
actuellement du Far-West à
al ou dans les autres
villes. Il faut y mettre un
ensemble de mesures pour pouvoir
prévoir. On a beau dire que le
gouvernement faut s'en occuper
mais les armes continuent de
rentrer. Les jeunes continuent
de tirer. Il faut mettre aussi
sur d'autres tables pour essayer
d'arrêter de banaliser la
culture des armes.
- J'avais revenir.
C'est la pensée magique.
Luc, sur la pensée des maires
qui sont aussi que ça chauffe
dans les villes...
- c'est bien. On a parlé de
problèmes d'armes qui
concernaient les cafés de
Montréal mais là on lui donne
une ampleur différente. C'est
toutes les grandes villes du
Québec. Jusqu'à Toronto et
Vancouver ils ont aussi les
mêmes demandes. Je ne pense pas
que les leaders vont pouvoir
rester dans la position de déni
dans laquelle ils se sont
installés, pour des raisons
différentes et de façons
différentes mais tous les deux
sont en déni.
- Je vais vous faire entendre
des petits extraits d'hier.
ERIN O'TOOLE, chef, Parti
conservateur du Canada
- Je vais maintenir
les restrictions en place
pour les armes à feu.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Je pense qu'il y a ici
un élément de leadership
extrêmement important où
monsieur O'Toole a refusé
de dire aux Québécois
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait faire, a
refusé de dires aux Canadiens
ce qu'il voulait faire.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chef, Bloc québécois
- Il faut éradiquer ce danger
qui rend les rues de Montréal...
Qui transforme les rues
de Montréal en champ de bataille
de gangs de rue et de crimes
organisés.
JAGMEET SINGH,
chef, Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Monsieur Trudeau a promis
d'avoir un (inaudible)
obligatoire, il a brisé
sa promesse.
ANNAMIE PAUL,
cheffe, Parti vert du Canada
- Il faut attaquer les racines :
l'inégalité, le manque
de logements abordables.
Il faut séparer ça en deux
catégories. Il y a les armes :
et le gouvernement fédéral
laisse aux villes le soin de les
interdire. Monsieur Trudeau a
dit : j'avais peut-être donné de
l'argent province pour qu'il
fasse. Les armes d'assaut il y
en a 1500 modèles qui ont été
interdits par un décret.
Ces deux choses différentes.
Comment vous voyez la suite des
choses?
- Les armes d'assaut, il y a
1500 armes semi-automatiques qui
ont été abolies par le projet de
loi C 21. Mais ce n'est pas ce
qu'il y a dans les rues.
Ce qui est utilisé parfois
hebdomadairement dans les rues
ce sont les armes de poing. Les
armes :, le gouvernement d
Trudeau dit qu'il va s'occuper
de cela d'une part et des
douanes.
Ça n'a pas fonctionné pour
l'instant. Je suis prêt à donner
1 milliard pour donner aux
villes mais je ne mettrai pas de
lois et règlements pour
renforcer cette interdiction.
C'est absurde. C'est absurde. On
ne peut pas avoir Ottawa qui
interdirait les armes, Kitchener
qui lui permettrait Montréal qui
les interdirait. Il faut se
demander pourquoi Trudeau
persiste et signe à ne pas
vouloir s'occuper des armes :?
- Vous êtes d'accord que les
armes de poings, ça été les
armes oubliées?
- Je rejoins mon collègue à 100
%. La raison pour laquelle
j'imagine que le fédéral ne peut
pas s'en occuper ses partisans
présentement en campagne
électorale et dans l'ouest du
Canada, les gens aiment les
armes tandis qu'au Québec on est
un peu à part. On est contre ça.
S'il légifère aujourd'hui,
quelques jours avant les
élections, c'est pour ça que
monsieur O'Toole et je crois
aussi que Monsieur Trudeau à la
même chose. Ils ont peur de
perdre un certain électorat et
ça, on ne peut pas devenir comme
les États-Unis au contraire. On
doit mettre un pied à terre. Le
leadership, c'est là que ça se
voit. Actuellement, il est
insensé de donner ce rôle aux
municipalités. On ne peut pas
gérer l'orgueil et l'aval
et Longueuil
de cette façon.
- Il faut envoyer le signal de
cet objet, on ne veut plus en
voir.
- Oui. Une des raisons
d'ailleurs... quand Trudeau
refuse les armes de poings, je
pense que c'est parce qu'il ne
veut pas entrer dans cette
bataille.
Elle nécessite beaucoup
d'intervention de la police sur
le terrain et donc qui peut être
accusé de profilage racial.
Plusieurs personnes sont dans
les gang de rue. Il ne peut pas
entrer là-dedans. Il ne veut pas
toucher à ça mais il va falloir
le faire il va falloir rentrer
là-dedans. Il va falloir trouver
des moyens d'enquête et de
perquisition.
C'est pour arrêter ce fléau.
Mais le fédéral ne veut pas y
aller. Alors à la limite que le
provincial prenne l'argent qu'il
dise pomper on va le faire pour
tout le Québec avec l'Ontario.
Si l'Ontario veut bien
l'interdire parce que si
l'Ontario ne veut pas
l'interdire alors on retourne à
la case zéro. Au moins tenter
cette alliance avec plusieurs
provinces.
- Dans la bataille municipale,
qu'on va entendre tous les
candidats de tous les parti dire
ça?
- Tout le monde entend là-
dessus. Oui tout le monde
devrait s'entendre là-dessus.
Pas de sécurité. Il faut aller
plus loin il faut aller changer
les lois. J'en ai déjà parlé il
y a quelques temps. On aboie
avoir... il faut changer les
lois et donner le pouvoir aux
policiers de le faire.
Actuellement, on s'exclame quand
les policiers tirent pour des
raisons pour leur travail
souvent... 10 fusillades cette
année. Dans les années 70, une
étude a été faite qui disait
pourquoi... qu'est-ce qu'ils
fêtent le plus peur dans la loi?
C'est le fait d'être pris en
train de le faire. Actuellement,
les policiers n'ont pas tous les
pouvoirs pour faire leur travail
ce qui fait que les jeunes
peuvent le faire impunément.
- Vous voulez dire?
- Le pouvoir d'aller plus loin
sur actuellement si les
policiers voient une gagnent de
jeune et qu'il est suspecté de
quelque chose qui n'ont pas
raison de les arrêter et non pas
tous les pouvoirs.
- Ils se sentent... il regarde
ailleurs.
- D'autres villes américaines
sont passées par là. À par
exemple à San Francisco, ils ont
voulu limiter au maximum les
interventions qui pourraient
être pénalisantes pour une
population assise et c'est vrai
que c'est pénalisant. C'est
vrai. Quand on a parlé de
profilage racial ce n'est pas
rien. Et on a des personnes
interpellées une centaine de
fois sur le trottoir parce qu'il
conduisait une voiture de luxe
parce qu'ils ont l'allure de
quelqu'un qu'on recherche. Le
profilage racial est un énorme
enjeu : il faut trouver le moyen
de faire des interventions sur
le terrain.
- Très difficile. On va en
reparler. C'est un enjeu
important dans cette campagne
électorale municipale qui a